hello everyone there are those chess
games that after you see them your day
is instantly improved and this is well
exactly such a game it was played in
1927 by the great polish Grandmaster
Miguel nya Dorf and although Miguel
neither was considered to be one of the
strongest players in the world in the
period of 1940s to 1950s this game was
actually played in the beginning of his
career I think he was about 17 years old
at the time this game was played and
Macallan I drove his playing with the
black pieces against Ignacio glücksburg
with the white pieces and a lot of
people are confusing this game to
another brilliancy and I have played
which is against a guy named the Gleeks
burg so it's it's definitely a different
guy and this is 1927 and the other game
is 1929 so I will show the other game as
well but this isn't that game and I
think rightfully this game is called the
Polish immortal and I'm sure you'll
agree with me that it definitely
deserves the title so like I said
Glucksberg is white and the night off is
black and oh yeah I wouldn't want to
miss this but you all know what great
contribution I have made to the chest
theory and I don't think there's a
really a chess player in the world that
hasn't tried the knight of variation of
the Sicilian defense okay so let's see
it again
now we have d4 and f5 the Dutch defense
we have c4 Knight to f6 Knight to c3 g6
Knight to f3 b5 Knight office preparing
the the stonewall defense something
often used by Magnus Carlsen himself
we have III c6 now the Stonewall is
complete Bishop to d3 we have Bishop to
b6 castles castles and out Knights to e2
and here we have a knight B to d7
Glucksberg goes for Knight to g5 and
this is a blunder matter of immediately
plays Bishop captures on h2 and well the
bishop can be captured but if King
captures Bishop then simply Knight to g4
check King g1 and the world the Queen
picks up the night and g5 and black is
up upon and well with a better position
so after Knight or played bishop
captures on h2o Godesberg plate simply
king - h1 and the now neither of place
again Knight to g4 and this opens up an
attack on this night on g5 so looks very
defense that he plays f4 and now neither
plays a queen to e8 as this King is
pretty much stuck here on h1 he can't go
anywhere and if the Queen gets the h5
this is well very dangerous so g3 is
played now making room for a king and g2
we have Queen to h5 by night off and now
King to g2 and this is move 13 why just
played the move 13 and the night of
place a brilliant move that completely
crushes White's position he plays Bishop
to g1 and well what's the threat here
well the threat is a very simple the
threat is going to h2 so let's see what
happens if this Bishop is captured and
the bishop must be captured because if
black tries white tries anything other
than capturing the bishop for example
Queen to e1 then it's over immediately
Quinta h2 check we are king to f3 and
out Queen to h1 checkmate so after this
Bishop to g1 move let's see what happens
if rook captures Bishop if ro captures
Bishop then again quint h2 check King to
f3 and queen to f2 checkmate
so it seems that the bishop cannot be
ignored but also the rook cannot capture
it so obviously the knight has to
capture the bishop so we have nice
capture Sanji 1 and now Queen to h2
check we have team to f3 and now the
rook is of course protecting f2 so going
to have to checkmate is no longer
available but neither of here continues
the game brilliantly he plays a5 and
this comes with a terrible threat the
threat is of course efore and well
capturing on e5 is definitely not
another very you know it's definitely
not pleasant to capture this but let's
see what happens if white ignores this
for example if he plays something like
Queen to d2 and offers a trade of Queens
then simply efore would check there is
no no square left for the block for the
white king so we have Bishop captures on
e4 d captures on e4 and now Knight
captures on e4
we have Queen to h1 check
now after Queen blocks the check with
Queen to g2 now simply F captures on e4
with check and this is over white loses
the Queen
so after this c5 obviously the e5 pawn
has to be captured we have D captures on
e5 and now Knight captures on e5 we have
F captures on e5 and now Knight to e5
check and what can y do here
well there is only one square for the
King it's king f4 and here we have
Knight to g6 with check King has to go
back to f3 and now definitely again a
brilliant continuation by night or we
have f4 and this comes with a terrible
threat this comes with a threat of F
captures an e3 orange e3 doesn't really
matter if this rook gets an open file
this is game over so what of course has
to capture we have a key captures on f4
and now a killing a kill this is I mean
this is an insta-kill try to find the
knight of next move
it's a beautiful one he plays Bishop to
g4 with check and if the King moves the
King the king can go to e3 but then this
Queen and the d1 falls so boots work
captures the bishop he plays King
captures and g4 and now neither of again
it's a blow by blow by blow
he plays Knight - if I would check and
with with this move
well white does have to capture the
night as now the F 3 square is covered
by the night and this Bishop sacrifice
and both the knight sacrifices were made
so that night off group and this F file
so we have F captures an e5 only move
and now I hope everyone can see it it's
checkmate in one to end the game in a
brilliant style as it was played we have
h5 so yeah definitely a beautiful
position and end a great date for Poland
so yeah I do hope you enjoyed this game
and well as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here and thank you
all for watching and I will see you soon